hallo sandro wie geht es dir
hallo immer danke gut und die
hallo immer danke gut und dir
auch gut ich habe
einen neuen freund
auch gut ich habe einen
freund
was erzählt
wir haben uns vor einem monat in einer
bar kennengelernt
danach haben wir uns verabredet
wir haben in einem restaurant zu abend
gegessen
[Musik]
dann sind wir zusammen
kino gegangen
dann sind wir zusammen ins kino gegangen
und bei unserem zweiten date haben wir
ein museum besucht
er kennt sich mit kunst aus
toll
er interessiert sich für kunst und
kultur
ja er interessiert sich für kunst und
das gefällt mir wir haben ähnliche
interessen
essen
außerdem machte wie ich
sport
außerdem machte wie ich gerne sport
beim dritten date sind wir zusammen ski
gefahren
an
beim dritten date sind wir zusammen ski
gefahren
das tönt ja super
als was arbeitet er
arbeitete
er ist arzt er arbeitet im krankenhaus
[Musik]
hast du ein foto von ihm
jetzt gerade nicht der akku von meinem
handy ist leer
beschreiben los
er ist größer als ich
er hat braune haare und braune augen
er hat braune haare
braune augen
er hat eine lange nase
er hat eine lange
da sind
er trägt eine brille
er hat ein kantiges gesicht
er ist sportlich
er ist gut angezogen
er ist gut
gezogen
er hat stil
er ist intelligent
er hat studiert
er ist großzügig
er leiht seine freunde oft ein
er lädt seine freunde oft ein
die nächste runde bezahle ich
die nächste runde
alle ich
er kam gut
kochen
er kann gut kochen
er macht gerne den haushalt
er hat einen guten job und verdient viel
geld
das ist ja ein traummann
das ist ja ein traum an
er hat blonde haare er hat blonde haare
seine haare sind blond seine haare sind
blond
er hat schwarze haare
seine haare sind schwarz seine haare
sind schwarz
er hat blaue augen er hat blaue augen
seine augen sind blau seine augen sind
blau
er hat braune augen er hat braune augen
er hat braune augen
seine augen sind braun seine augen sind
braun
er hat eine schmale nase
er hat eine kleine nase er hat eine
kleine nase
er hat eine große nase er hat eine große
nase
er hat ein eckiges kinn er hat ein
eckiges kinn
er hat ein spitzes kinn er hat ein
spitzes kinn
er hat ein rundes kinn er hat ein rundes
kinn
er hat ein markantes kinn er hat ein
markantes kinn
er hat ein doppelkinn er hat ein
doppelkinn
er hat ein freundliches lächeln
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video